There's nothing quite like curling up on the
sofa and marathoning Netflix's fine film selection.
these are just a few of the flicks that deserve
way more attention than they're getting.
Part apocalyptic thriller, part family drama,
the Ellen Page- and Evan Rachel Wood-led Into
The Forest is a compelling, unsettling movie
that never quite goes where the viewer thinks
it's going.
Deep inside a beautiful, remote forest, sisters
Nell and Eva live in a stately, window-covered
home with their father, played by Callum Keith
Rennie.
There's been a far-reaching collapse of the
national grid, but Nell and Eva continue to
live their lives as best they can until the
power comes back.
Spoiler alert: It doesn't.
Time passes agonizingly, the food and supply
reserves dwindle, and some truly horrific
things happen as Nell and Eva, far from civilization,
wonder if society has completely collapsed,
and fight for the lives they once took for
granted.
Eventually, they can't wait around anymore
and must fend for themselves by heading…
into the forest.
The occasional bad gig is a necessary stumbling
block for a young band paying its dues, but
hear us out: Green Room isn't a Spinal Tap-esque
comedy about the indignities musicians face.
"Let me call my cousin.
I can get you guys a solid gig."
"Where?
Here?"
"Scene's dead.
You'd have to dip down closer to Portland."
Instead, it's a claustrophobic, intense, and
at times horrific pulse-pounder about a regular
punk band, whose members include Imogen Poots,
Alia Shawkat, and the late Anton Yelchin,
who get waylaid and trapped in the "green
room," the backstage waiting area, of a concert
venue.
Surprise!
It turns out the place is actually a Nazi
skinhead bar, and one of the musicians just
so happened to catch a glimpse of the body
of a recently murdered woman.
As a result, the bad guys hold the band hostage
until they can kill them.
Their leader is the worst of all, portrayed
by a very much against-type Patrick Stewart.
Needless to say, he steals the spotlight.
Well, he steals it and he stomps it to pieces.
It's an intense, compelling, low-budget horror
movie of a different stripe, and one from
which not everyone gets out alive, or intact.
Over the last decade or so, the Chinese film
industry has exploded, producing big movies
on par with Hollywood blockbusters.
And as the Western canon provides a rich history
of fantasy, take The Lord of the Rings, for
example, so too does China with Novoland,
a sprawling, 30-book series written by multiple
authors that concerns a made-up, quasi-medieval
and magical universe.
Legend of the Naga Pearls marks Novoland's
auspicious U.S. streaming debut.
The story is set in the mythical city of Uranapolis,
where ho-hum humans and the angel-like Winged
Tribe lived side-by-side, but not without
some hostility, of course.
A war between the races led to the dominance
of the humans and the Winged Tribe losing
its flying abilities.
The movie picks up with an understandably
angry descendant of the most royal of the
Winged Tribe, played by Simon Lam, going on
an adventure to locate the fabled Naga Pearls,
which would destroy the humans once and for
all.
Those pearls, however, accidentally wind up
in the possession of a human prince, constable,
and thief, and they do everything they can
to keep them out of their enemy's hands, a
process which involves epic battles and dazzling
fight and flight sequences that'll turn even
the most jaded viewer into a fan for life.
"Freeze, you jive-time suckas!"
The only-in-the-'70s film genre known as "blaxploitation,"
hip, fight sequence-loaded action rides featuring
predominantly African-American casts, is spoofed
in loving detail in Black Dynamite, a quirky,
compelling, and extremely hilarious midnight
movie.
Co-writer and star Michael Jai White shows
off his impressive martial arts skills, film
history knowledge, and ability to crack the
perfect one-liners as the titular Black Dynamite,
a one-man army and ex-CIA operative now set
on single-handedly fixing some problems both
personal and societal by going after "The
Man."
Who's the man?
Pure evil, what with how he killed Black Dynamite's
brother, wants to get orphans addicted to
drugs, and introduced an extra-strong malt
liquor into the black community that shrinks
the, ahem, male reproductive organ.
"Anaconda Malt Liquor gives you…
Little Richard?"
The plot is totally over the top in this adventure
inspired by Shaft and Superfly, except those
flicks unfortunately didn't have any scenes
set on "Kung Fu Island," or mistakes thrown
in on purpose to make the movie look like
a homemade labor of love.
Dynamite!